when you start to think about how this
affects uh kind of the bitcoin and
crypto market uh there's obviously a
macro impact for sure uh but there's
also some things around uh the nuances
of the industry itself uh we've seen
contagion throughout the market we've
seen asset prices crashing we've seen a
ton of
kind of chain reactions what's your
general feel for where we are right now
should we still be worried about some of
this contagion should we be worried
about future failures of businesses or
of assets uh is there a little bit of a
lull and relief and everyone can kind of
take a deep breath uh which may be in
contrast to what happened over the last
three or four weeks like how are you
feeling about it and what are you
thinking at the moment
yeah so i mean certainly we've seen a
lot of pain uh it's there's been almost
no relief for the longest time just just
consolidation and straight down and
actually one of the more kind of
worrying things from just
analyzing trends is that you know nasdaq
s s p 500 bitcoin correlations have been
very positive for all of 2022 uh to the
downside and upside and in recent weeks
we've seen that correlation that beta
really intensify on downside moves and
an upside moves bitcoin is
just kind of you know laid flat it
hasn't really responded too well i think
uh because of all of the kind of
contagion because of all of the risk off
because of all the off-balance sheet
debt that no one really knew existed
you're seeing a lot of risk managers
from the legacy world that you know even
if they think hey this is this is really
really cheap bitcoin is here to stay you
know they're getting a tap on their
shoulder from their risk managers from
their senior guys at the funds they work
out they're saying hey we can't touch
this right now the market's very very
liquid it's moving up five or you know
five percent or down five percent just
on you know a 500 million dollars in the
futures market it's it's too illiquid
for us to take a take a sizable position
here and we need to cut risk in general
so i think that's one uh the second is
that you know miners are going to
continue to face some pressure there
will be kind of an uh
a full style capitulation and transfer
of of coins and asics from from weak to
strong hands that's in the process of
occurring it's obviously it's obviously
started today would say a core
scientific selling 86 of their bitcoin
holdings over the course of june and i
think the next is that you know there's
a big lesson here in the in the
crypto world broadly uh and one not your
keys not your coins that's been repeated
ad nauseum and i think a bunch of people
understand that but two is i think some
of the marketing um from from these
lending and yield uh desks and companies
around the space uh in terms of like
advertising it as a savings account when
really uh you know they were taking
deposits rehypothecating uh and and
chasing yield through kind of various
arb strategies various uh funds uh you
know getting their funds to hedge funds
and et cetera i think that
in in terms of
having a lasting and an effective
business strategy
i think that needs to change and and
obviously you know yield and financial
services aren't going anywhere but
it needs to be advertised more clearly
to consumers other than just fine print
because a lot of people thought they
were just saving their bitcoin and
getting an interest rate like they do at
a bank but ultimately the risk-free rate
of bitcoin is zero percent and any other
yield on top of that requires some risk
premium and then ultimately there's risk
being taken so i guess that's my like my
three main takeaways here um i expect
bitcoin to kind of chop around uh in
kind of an accumulation phase for a
while and if we do see kind of uh
everything correlation to one event
which i suspect is still to come in the
legacy market bitcoin will see some
downside pressure uh but really all the
historical indicators that i see
from capitulation from miners to macro
conditions uh to just you know price
action and and trends previous to
all-time highs bitcoin's a deep value
here but that doesn't mean it's going to
send it to all-time highs tomorrow so
patience is the name of the game uh you
know learn best practices self-custody
and just understand that you know in the
end there is no kind of escaping the
perpetual credit expansion of the fiat
system